i tell you with ronnie he as soon as he
got vaccinated he started going out and
what happened over vacation he got the
worst [ __ ] cold ever because
did he oh yeah because you know he's
running around screaming and yelling and
carrying on not only did i have a cold
what do you think you got sick from do
you have any idea
i don't know usually what's that thing
starve a fever
feed a cold no i think it's the opposite
feed a fever starve a cold i think
whatever
oh dear oh
yeah and that was a lot worse believe me
are you excited to have sex in your new
house oh yeah i can't wait even said to
robin like
who moves to vegas honestly this summer
in the summer
do you know what gets up to 120 degrees
in las vegas
and ronnie has like horrible skin for
the sun he's like all red and raw
and white and moles you got tons of
moles dude
i went to get tattooed with you you're
going to fry up like a piece of bacon
yeah you know when i'm picturing ronnie
in the pool and like
you see those old guys in florida that
are brown
or you ever see you ever see those new
things they put little kids in
it's like a full like almost like a
wetsuit because ronnie can't
how's ronnie gonna sit in a pool i don't
care how much sunscreen he puts on that
hairy body of his
yeah you're hairy dude back when we had
that
that tv show we shaved uh messages in
his back
how hairy he was this is an end of life
crisis
you heard a midlife crisis this is an
end-of-life crisis and he's making bad
decisions i just can't deal with with
the manhattan
deal anymore the traffic all the idiots
that
you know i just can't deal with it
ronnie's like 71 and i think they said
like the average life expectancy now in
this country is 77
and a half so really you know yeah oh
there you're killing runners
what are you doing here ronnie only has
a few years
six he's got six good years yeah exactly
and he's gonna go back in a pool
somewhere
stephanie called vegas tell him to dig
faster i gotta get that house
by the way do you notice ronnie's
background he's boxed up all his junk
everything's boxed up except the hood of
the car
yeah well i i got to get mirror boxes
for those when you get some mirror boxes
no you don't
do you know what impact yeah exactly
leave that on the wall for the new
owners
nah that's okay i did get word that you
packed up
lube [ __ ] rings stephanie's vibrator and
the jackhammer it's already packed for
vegas
wow and some of our favorite porno
movies oh you got to see all the porno
we threw out
oh my god it was insane the porno that
got thrown out of this house
you had that much huh we sat there on
saturday actually
we were sitting in the middle of the
living room and we had them all piled up
on the floor
yeah with a big like 50 gallon garbage
bag
and we were going through all of them
saying should we take this one should we
take that one no we don't want that one
well you got to do the marie condo thing
you look at it and you go
does anal fist party eight spark joy if
not
thank this video and then throw it in
the plastic bag and get rid of it i
threw out some really really good pornos
magnum p-u-s-s-y a tale of two titties
the [ __ ] father you threw them all out
huh i threw em all out yeah
you